hey this is pressure Locker this problem
has been shared millions of times on
Facebook and Twitter with the claim that
99% failed to solve it and that only a
genius could find the correct answer in
this video I'm going to explain what
many people believe to be the correct
answer can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution so
most people believe the correct answer
is 6 the pattern is to take the number
on the left hand side of the equation
and multiply it by 1 less than itself
for example the first line would read 9
times 8 which equals 72 the next line
would be 8 times 7 which equals 56 we
then have 7 times 6 which equals 42 6
times 5 which equals 35 times 4 which
equals 20 and finally we would have 3
times 2 which equals 6
but not everyone believes 6 is the
correct answer
some people argue the correct answer is
12 they identify a pattern of decreasing
subtraction in the number on the right
hand side so let's see how this pattern
works we start out with 9 equals 72 to
get to the next line we subtract by 16
to get 256 so that is why 8 equals 56
now how do we get to the next line
rather than subtracting by 16 they would
say you should decrease the amount
you're subtracting by to be 14 so then
we have 56 minus 14 equals 42 this gives
us the next line of 7 equals 42 we now
subtract by 2 less so we have 42 minus
12 which equals 3
and that gets us to the next line we
then subtract by two less again so we
have 30 minus 10 which equals 20 so we
have 5 equals 20 and then we want to
subtract by 2 less which will be 8 and
that'll be 20 minus 8 which equals 12
and that's why they argue the answer is
3 equals 12 but hold on there's a third
group of people who say the answer is
neither six nor twelve but actually that
the answer is nine their method is
looking at a pattern of decreasing
multiplication so this is very much like
the answer being six you multiply a
number by one less than itself the
difference in this method is now they
say look at the numbers you're
multiplying by this is a sequence of
numbers we have eight seven six five and
four so this group of people argues that
if you decrease this you would get the
next line which means you should
multiply the next line by three so they
would say the answer is three times
three which equals nine
so now let's recap the three different
answers some people say the answer is
six other people say the answer is 12
and even other people say the answer is
nine now it's a common question which of
these answers is correct is there a more
correct answer than any of the others
well from the information we're given in
the puzzle we can't definitively say but
what we can do is we can ask is any of
these answers justifiable under the
patterns of the given methods and by
that standard the answer of six is
justifiable by the two other methods we
can actually reconcile this to show that
six is a very reasonable answer how can
we do that let's start out with the
logic of the decreasing subtraction so
here's the information of the pattern
each time you're subtracting by two less
than before
so now the question is is there are
there any other patterns in this when
what you can do is focus on the first
number in each line we have the sequence
here we have nine eight seven six and
five by this logic that we should have a
sequence we should then have a sequence
that the next line be one less than five
so the next line should be four and by
the logic of decreasing subtraction we
would then have four equals twelve so
then how do we figure out what the next
line is how do we get to what 3 equals
well we look at the numbers we're
subtracting by if we have this logic of
decreasing subtraction we should
subtract by two less than eight so that
means the next line would have 12 minus
6 and that would give us the answer on
the right-hand side of the next line
which equals 6 so if we decrease 4 we
then have the next line being 3 and then
we have the answer of 6 by this
decreasing subtraction method so once
again we figured out that 3 equals 6 and
the answer is 6 by the very same
decreasing subtraction method the only
thing we had to do is we had to add the
missing line of 4 equals 12 we can use
the same kind of logic for the
decreasing multiplication method here's
an information from the pattern which
they argue about the decreasing
multiplication method so we're supposed
to be looking for a logic to this these
numbers well what we can do is we can
look at the first number in every single
line we have a sequence here of numbers
9 8 7 6 and 5 so logic would suggest the
next line should start out with 4 we
then look at the numbers that were
multiplying by and that's another
sequence 8 7 6 5 & 4 so logic would
suggest the next line should be
multiplied by 3 so the next line should
be 4 multiplied by 3 equals 12
if we continue this pattern the first
number will be one less and the second
number will be one less so the next line
would be three times two and once again
three times two equals six so we again
have the answer being equal to six this
is even true under the decreasing
multiplication method as long as we
include the missing line of four times
three equals 12
so to recap it doesn't matter which
method we're using we're always going to
get to the answer that three equals six
and in fact we would have four equals 12
in each of these methods too so this
logic would suggest that the correct
answer to this puzzle is that three
equals six what do you think thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch remember my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at
pressure Locker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description